how was it i know you're you're coming
back right for an episode of the flash
mm-hmm
superman is right you're superman no
adam oh that's ray palmer
yes
so he's coming back in a flash episode
coming out relatively soon the
november 19th i think it's the beginning
of they're doing like a mini mini
crossover first five episodes of flash
and so ray and adam are in the first
uh the first episode right and you did
the 100th episode right 100th episode of
flat of legends yep and now how now how
is that like um
finding out like they're like hey we're
not going to um have your character
return in legends was that i mean did
they do you right did they approach you
right did they tell you that this is
going to end in the in the way you
wanted to hear it ultimately it's been a
journey
for me of learning uh and appreciating
and uh
cultivating my own self-worth yeah well
they keep bringing you back so it's not
like women like you and uh you know
people make decisions
right people make some people sometimes
people make good decisions and sometimes
people make bad decisions right um bad
decisions happen all the time all the
time um
all the time
and sometimes they affect us uh
negatively and we can choose to be upset
with that for the rest of our lives
or we can work to
come to terms with it i guess
and to find as they say make
lemonade
out of lemons
um
and you know that's what that's what
i've been working on doing and i think i
speak for courtney and saying the same
thing
um and knowing meanwhile by fan reaction
and all the love we've gotten over the
last couple years that
even though one person made this
decision that was a bad decision um
nobody supports that
right nobody has supported that decision
um
uh and uh and so that's one reason why
one of the reasons why we said yes to
come back because
i i
we knew that it would it would be
the fans would appreciate it
um and also we you know
we we
we made sure that in coming back
that we would be
that we were standing in our own worth
and and made our own
uh requests
to
make sure that we were
felt like
we were being respected yes and that
happened this time around so yeah we
were happy to be a a part of it and uh
and also to get an opportunity to work
again with with wentworth
uh and and victor and faulk uh some
people who who in france also who didn't
have as much opportunity to be in the
season four energy of legends kind of
more goofy open so it was fun to kind of
play with them in that new sandbox that
the show had become where it wasn't it
wasn't that way as much when they
started out